come on in I how are you hi nice to see
you min you are shri keys here how are
you come to the show welcome d-bag it's
a lovely dress by the way our enamel on
that dress you do look great
our producer here sick baby he was
obsessed with you growing up but he got
so nervous that you were coming that he
just saw a girl walking up the hallway
and he ran in here and told us you were
coming in right now and I was like five
minutes ago she looked nothing like you
guys she's a blonde look at his wedding
yeah he's scaring the sweat see these
very I was hurt you liked it and I tried
to let him off the hook I'm like well he
probably didn't know she was he's like
Dolly was obsessed with her shoes so how
would you have thought that was her yeah
mine sweetie comment I guess I got all
nervous and excited you did let's go
with that okay Dadar I'm an idiot
football about dollar salon yeah yeah
that mutually nervous excited just a
nervous [ __ ] love it all right well
good welcome to the show thank you and
you must be yeah well it's good to have
you here you got a new series coming out
yes oh hey yeah hey yep
what is it on Hulu it's not shut I mean
the whole thing drops right the whole
thing jobs all 10 episodes yes uh which
is exciting
cuz that's how I like to watch TV like
when I find something that I love I just
want to keep going marathon style so um
yep they all drop is there no part that
like because the one nice thing about
being on an episodic series is that you
put all this work into it and then you
get the feedback on it for like months
right yeah whereas this one
theoretically it's like you could have
this big blast this weekend and then
move on to the next thing but you know
what there's so much content right now
like there's so much that you never know
who's going to decide to binge when I
mean hopefully that I know I just binge
dumb masters of sex
what is that right you know no man I've
ever heard of masters of sex I'm sure I
go skiing what's your mouth are you
kidding really don't know he's right
show time that's a show time show don't
know it now yes very very popular show
oh there yeah how much is bad I just
interested that's
boyfriend is that familiar that guy yep
yeah he's a the Kathlyn I'm obsessed
with her so but that's like a proper
example and that's been on for years so
I I hear what you're saying but no I
guess not right yes like Westworld just
ended and literally people were coming
up to me now cuz they all heard about
how great the finale was and being like
I start watching that's exactly yeah
especially during the holidays the
holidays is a great time because we have
downtime to just watch our is oh tell
what's your show about it's the backdrop
is psychics in Los Angeles and the
Romani families that run them and the
cons you know that can't be done and
Jeffrey Donovan the male lead of our
show he does he's a psychic he works as
a psychic mostly calling people and he
gets a knock to the head and suddenly he
starts to get like real hits of
intuition real visions so you're sort of
straddling both of real not real have
you ever been - I've never gone to a
psychic okay I might have went to one
one as a GU as a goof to see yeah I
didn't get anything out of it did you go
to one - I have I don't I don't
gravitate towards psychics like this I
love getting a tarot card reading done
or astrology reading done over going to
a psychic but what the psychic tell you
is there any accuracy to it I honestly I
barely remember it must have not left a
very big impression they're really good
reads of personalities like it like
penpen July talks about how they do like
these these readings and they're very
smart and they're very intuitive so we
kind of know how to lead you yes and
they don't they're amazed that general
truths ours they can make these likes
and see how you react to this amazing
you've lost the war leader yeah oh yeah
everyone has I talked to one and she
said that mostly her job is telling
wives that their husbands are cheating
on them that's why most women will come
to figure out like is he cheating on me
but if you're that like if you have to
story line is it yeah you don't to be a
psychic to know that just check my text
messages better cheater you under old me
I think though if you're in a
relationship where you're going to a
psychic to find out if your husband's
cheating on you he's cheating on you
right like if you have that insecurity
bottle then you know the same way I
think we all like if you're gonna go see
a psychic about something deep down you
have a feeling about it already
right right PS if you're going to a
psychic to know whether or not your
husband's having an affair like
obviously things are not right at home
have you ever been cheated on yes how'd
you find out psychic
could you imagine no no way but I'm
always hidden how people get caught like
was it right no no no I got it
so a woman's intuition yep it's a very
powerful real thing
yeah and I was in I was in a long
relationship so in love it was like the
first love of my life and he was in a in
a musical and the understudy was on and
I remember like after the show I went to
the dressing room and she comes like
sort of like skipping in and she sees me
and she's like oh what a terrible couple
sorry oh I'll come back and I remember
just being like yeah okay why would she
have some Emma helmet justice it was
this like microscopic moment but it hit
me so hard and in all fairness he ended
up telling me so you did you mention it
to him in that moment I don't remember
but I know we had a conversation not
right in that moment not right in that
Malaysia heater but certainly like he
went that night or the next day
why couldn't you play cool like just
first oh good shot of seeing her they
have a super highway yeah exactly
it was just that and it was sort of like
it worked out perfectly like I like I
found out everything I needed to in that
moment and it was devastating what did I
say he finally said yeah I'm seeing her
it was a one-time thing
I know it wasn't a one-time thing okay
den Nega worse I think men are awful no
matter how you say I mean this was a tit
I was so young and it was really my
first love and I felt like traumatized
by that experience for years I just
trust his shoes and like ste and I have
had a great relationship with my father
he's no longer alive that's why I said
had but um you know so it wasn't even
that I was I have a good amazing father
figure in my life so that was just
traumatic and yet PS I'm fine and I
think it's growing pains yeah and the
thing you learn and that's do you need a
boyfriend no I have a good one yes baby
hands over there yeah he really does
have little teeny boneless baby hair
colors fingers yeah is [ __ ] real
hands are doing you well boneless
chicken wings how do you usually get
caught Jim you know I don't care co-op
did you ever get cheated on how could I
not I'm sure I had been yeah I'm sure it
happened yeah but you don't get caught I
got caught once cheating yeah but I kind
of confessed she knew and didn't you
didn't you also once like didn't weren't
you printing out text messages or
something yeah but I hadn't cheated with
that girl what do you mean print I tell
true story on stage of a girl caught me
I dirty texted with his girl and I had
hit the wrong button this is the truth
and I was on Wi-Fi and I printed the
entire conversation and it's the truth
and I printed by mistake did you
actually want to print him complete
mistake yeah the only the only reason
even print my girlfriend at the time
didn't didn't drive a knife into me
because she won't be up that and the
next morning was because it was obvious
by the text that the girl and I had
never hung out we had we're just talking
I was just just a conversational thing
like hey we were gonna hang out because
I intrigue a lot like I like that a lot
more even than hanging out because I
find that there's no risk and intriguing
or hang out this things can happen to
that dirty texting would have been
enough for my wife no it would have been
but again in when she knows I probably
could have hung out with the person
didn't this times right back to off like
it could have happened
all right cool and then just didn't do
it yeah so I think she knew but that
that did end our relationship eventually
I'm not that you really won't need to
hear all this but I took her to Vegas
I'm like it'll be okay I'll make it up
we stayed in a great hotel then I got
food poisoning and [ __ ] for 24 hours but
it was kind of was it was justified you
know yeah I deserve that Norma right
there she didn't cheat on me I think
that she was like your sexy girl and she
could have been absolutely could have
done better than me and she didn't so I
deserve yeah yeah oh boy don't crab in
Vegas don't eat crab in Vegas - yeah
come on honey ah yeah yeah was really
bad news oh my god yeah you still are
you shocked uh at this point that people
are still because I'm sure people still
come up to you talk about Entourage like
is that like mind-blowing to you
or or does it feel like yeah that was
impactful
ah yeah more the latter I think you know
what it is I think that the times have
changed so much so that first of all we
when we were doing the show there was no
social media right we were instagramming
we weren't tweeting we weren't any of
that it's amazing
it's unbelievable on whenever you want
to use freedom yeah when did it start so
I've joined it says this for dude yeah
something like that
right I think so yeah so we didn't have
any of that so what's happening to is
that with you know binge watching and
on-demand and at the top there isn't
there's a new audience so now the 18 19
year olds are like oh my god I'm
obsessed with Entourage and they're
discovering it right now goes right back
to the binge thing and they're talking
about a horse oh yeah yeah and so it's
really it's flattering and I think it's
really cool that a different generation
still enjoys it so much yeah you know
what I mean yeah I think it's nice yeah
fine
we have you have to live tweet your new
show or anything not I mean we haven't
been alive tweet yet but I mean yes at
this entire promotional tour of my
Instagram the
week is its Oh rabbits I'm tweeting read
it's just it's literally become part of
the job I think it's in your contract
now yeah a little a social media yeah
yeah is there people that if you don't
have a Twitter account it's like alright
we're gonna have to sign up for Twitter
yeah and get some followers so you can
tweet this sometimes they over rate the
impact of it like it does help to get
the word out but I think sometimes they
over rate the impact of it as well like
they think oh my god you've a million
Twitter insecure that can help but it's
not gonna guarantee success right yeah I
understand be with really boring fact I
just do not the details are important to
be a good real advertising buzz about
you Jim talk about it write something
nice and pessimistic yeah yeah
your jewelry is phenomenal i I don't
usually go for it exactly they're your
range on your shears these two
tremendous rings three out of the four
and I immediately looked at the ring
finger like with the wedding ring like
why would I look at the like I don't
make sure she wasn't she nobody isn't it
as a guy you just look at that though
she just said she's very happy with her
boyfriend I know I respect that
is he an actor yes very handsome yeah
yeah dress I never dated the industry
because they they don't want to and be
they have other choices that's true by
the way you're not welcome in the
industry no that's a great question
he's not an actor he is an actor isn't
it but you know I it's true I was so not
about dating an actor yeah had you
worked on a project before with him or
did you meet Internet we met through
friends we did yeah that that kind of
updated one actress casually and it was
we met at a cast function but we don't
address I can't say oh I can't say I'm
not saying that she's not a big actress
I'm saying that to be lame classy it
wasn't really I didn't date that was a
sexual thing oh listen everybody the new
10 episode series
shut eye is out now on Hulu it sounds
really really fresh and interesting it's
cool so uh absolutely cool and that's
the best part you could check out like
the first episode to see if you like it
and then assuming you do they're all
there for you except let me just say
because I believe this to be true
across the board I don't I think it's
tough to judge the pilot of any show
sure and then you have to really give
any [ __ ] like their shows that I'm
obsessed with that I got hooked in by
the third episode yeah this is a lot of
setting up with the wires like you just
keep you thinking about absolutely yeah
so give it a couple yeah bend your heart
out pilots are basically present you
know basically pilot sure to let you
know this is the person this what they
do this the person that's what they do
this way you understand and then they
can really create yeah there's just a
lot of setup and plus if you're Benji
just watch a couple write this I give to
waste three night to your life for three
day three weeks
yeah just watch three yeah like is your
character good or evil it's cool she's
Shady
oh yeah she's a hypnotist from Vegas and
she's a hustler wow that's cool like
dying cuz you were pretty sweet your
other show yeah and you're kind of a
sweet person must be fun to play someone
a little it is it was it was really um
as far creatively speaking it was a
really dreamy gig that's cool yeah well
watch set watch shut-eye yes tonight and
tomorrow because you'll be busy on
Friday watching Tom Pappas special a
human mule on epics yes oh shoot
Doyle's town Pennsylvania where you'll
be seeing this is all work Tom that's
right thank you and wait till Friday
wait to hear this mmm cuz your might be
like oh I don't have to wreck TV I don't
have epics if you go to epics calm it's
free this month
perfect giving you away the only other
binge one hour that's true right and
with instead there's no pilot so you get
through the first 10 minutes and if you
like you watch there's a comedian to
give it the first 10 minute breaks under
Sabo so like just just bear with me for
10 minutes yeah we set up who I am yeah
I've uh I've watched graphics of shakers
and of course Jim Norton calm for all
your dates right yeah I only have two
more besides this this the shoot um so
yeah shall I and it's a shrieky a chri q
UI and now family's Israeli right
Moroccan okay cuz I read that you were
your family's very like oh you kind of
Orthodox listen yeah I grew up that way
you know you did
yeah so we they like horrify when you
want to act
no no not at all actually my my parents
were incredibly supportive but my mom's
family where she came from
they were like very religious they grew
up in Morocco and my mother was an
incredibly beautiful woman and I think
at some point the story goes that they
wanted her to be like Miss Casablanca
and and and her family was like no it's
four-horse
I will not have a [ __ ] under this room
yes that really makes you want to meet
miss Casablanca she sounds like a good
egg well this was great
yeah I'm thank you for stopping by thank
you mom